good evening welcome to Washington I'm
Mike Emanuel in for Bret Baier president
Trump met with retired Special
Operations chief Eddie Gallagher at
mar-a-lago this week after supporting
him through his war crimes trial a
military jury acquitted Gallagher of
murdering a captured in Islamic state
fighters but convicted him of illegally
posing with the detainees corpse the
president reversed the court's decision
to lower Gallagher's rank and pay today
the New York Times released video of
Gallagher's fellow Navy SEALs calling
him evil toxic and someone who was
willing to kill anybody
that was moving Lucas Tomlinson is at
the Pentagon looking at the rare break
in the military code of silence this is
how Navy SEALs and Eddie Gallagher's
platoon describe the veteran of inked
combat deployments used of killing a
wounded Isis fighter team sevens alphab
soon gave Gallagher a nickname blade Fox
News has not authenticated the video
this photo appears to be from the 2017
deployment to Iraq in question it
appears to show chief Gallagher and a
seal platoon over the body of a deceased
Isis fighter who Gallagher was accused
of killing by some of his fellow seals
he's probably just like a stab right
here just in a few times there's no way
this was anything other than to attack
and it killed this person now
what did you do next if I stayed at the
scene until the Isis fighter asphyxiated
but during Gallagher's trial Navy SEAL
Corey Scott changed his story while on
the witness stand you didn't say the
chief Gallagher suffocated no Craig
Miller self again no did you suffocate
him yes now I held my thumb over his eg2
until he stopped hurting Gallagher
responded through his lawyer quote my
first reaction to seeing the videos was
surprised and discussed that they would
make up blatant lies about me but I
quickly realized that they were scared
that the truth would come out of how
cowardly they acted on deployment
Gallagher was found not guilty of
killing the ISIS militant in a trial
last summer but was found guilty of a
lesser charge posing for this photo and
was convicted and demoted until
President Trump intervened in late
November I wanted to take his pin away
and I said no you're not gonna take it
away he was a great fighter he was the
one of the ultimate fighters tough guy
these are not weak people these are
tough people the president has not shied
away from his support for Eddie
Gallagher after pardoning him hosting
the accused war criminal and his
mar-a-lago estate on Christmas Eve
US defense officials say the Navy SEALs
top admiral Colin green wanted to
convene a board to see if Gallagher's
coveted tried and pin the mark of a Navy
SEAL should be stripped this is all
about ego and retaliation this has
nothing to do with good order and
discipline
Eddie Gallagher's lawyer tells FOX News
late today Navy SEAL Corey Scott never
changed his story since Scott said all
along how the ISIS fighter died but he
never said how until the trial officials
tell me this story is ripping the seals
apart Mike Lucas Tomlinson leading us
off live from the Pentagon Lucas many
thanks